you would be hard-pressed to find many
folks who don't know indiana jones
nowadays the legacy of the indiana jones
films is enduring thanks in part to it
having no shortage of memorable moments
here are some of the most paused scenes
in the indiana jones movies
in the opening sequence of raiders of
the lost ark director steven spielberg
does an incredible job of letting us
know exactly what indiana jones is all
about there are puzzles traps betrayal
and a giant boulder hell-bent on
smushing our hero indy navigates a
sequence of deadly traps and arrives at
the treasure he seeks we're then left in
suspense as he stares down a grimacing
gold relic the moment hangs in the air
for longer than expected but rather than
the hesitation making us anxious we wait
patiently we trust that indy knows what
he's doing given that we only met this
man minutes earlier it's quite an
achievement plus we get to find out what
that sack full of sand is all about
indiana jones presents himself as a
fearless protagonist throughout the
entire film series however there's no
denying the fear in his eyes when faced
with a serpent
i hate snake shark i hate him
come on show a little bath bomb will ya
the temple which houses the titular ark
is crawling with the slithery devils a
setting befitting the dangerous power
contained within the ark of the covenant
andy hijacks a portion of the nazi dig
site in the desert once he discovers the
real location of the ark there's a
moment that follows when andy falls to
the ground and looks up to discover he's
face to face with a hissing cobra he
locks eyes with the creature before
scrambling away and in that moment you
see the normally stoic action hero have
a base of pure panic
even if you lock him in an ancient snake
riddled throne room that hasn't been
opened in thousands of years indiana
jones will still find an exit which in
this instance is also conveniently near
a nazi-occupied airstrip good thing too
because at this point in raiders it's
been far too long since we've seen
indiana engaged in fisticuffs
fortunately our lust for action is
satiated by a burly mustachioed nazi
who's eager for battle indy isn't always
the top dog in a fight but when he lacks
in fighting prowess he makes up for an
ingenuity his enemy in the scene looks
formidable but indy always manages to
find a clever way to overcome his
opponent however in this case defeating
this gladiator nazi on the airstrip is
entirely a matter of blind luck a series
of events that has to happen for this
final boss to go face first and airplane
propeller blades is fantastically silly
and truly a wonder to behold
the ark of the covenant is shrouded in
mystery for most of the first film we're
left in the dark as to what exactly is
contained within that beautiful gold
sarcophagus after indy combats nazis
across the globe for over 90 minutes
it's time for the final reveal of the
ark with all we have emotionally
invested in the journey what lies inside
that ancient tomb best be mind-blowing
and it lives up to that expectation when
marion is nabbed by the evil doers andy
trails them atop a submarine eventually
arriving in an isolated island india
doesn't do so well in foiling any plans
and winds up tied to a stake on a
mountaintop while the bad guys
ceremoniously open the ark what's
unleashed is an unholy wave of
destruction among the nazis as the
spirits whip around and annihilate
anything that looks at them a viewing
experience that continues to deliver the
goods over and over again
the opening scene of temple of doom had
a lot to live up to considering the now
iconic boulder chase scene in the first
film the second film in the series opens
with a glamorous show tune with lots of
sparkly dresses moments later instep's
indiana jones not clothed in his usual
leather jacket in fedora but in a fancy
white tuxedo there's an exchange taking
place between jones and some shady
characters we don't exactly know what's
being traded but that's not the point
the point is harrison ford looks sharp
and it's time for another adventure an
acknowledgment of a successful deal indy
lifts a glass of champagne and gulps it
down the bad men began cackling with
laughter because our hero just drank
poison the antidote is in an extremely
durable vial that winds up being kicked
around the dance floor while the entire
dining room erupts into chaos watching
indy scramble about chasing the vial
around the dance floor is a fun comical
experience
when indiana jones and the temple of
doom was released in 1984 there was no
such thing as a pg-13 rating thanks to
the nightmare fuel that was tossed on an
entire generation of kids who saw this
pg-rated installment of indiana jones
the motion picture association of
america decided to create a rating to
bridge the gap between pg and r ratings
in temple of doom circumstances result
in indiana and his companions being
stranded in india after a plane crash
all roads forced them to a society
housing a dark secret mostly a
mind-controlling shaman named mularam
who leads an army of acolytes with
aspirations of world domination and he
gets backrow seats to one of their
ceremonies and witnesses rom uses bare
hand to reach into a man's chest and
pull out his heart he then holds the
still-beating heart while the man
remains alive long enough to be lowered
into a lava pit as a man screams in
agony below the heart and rom's hand
bursts into flames it's a haunting image
that certainly warranted a
re-examination of our movie rating
system
in temple of doom indiana jones manages
to escape his captors in a wild mine
cart ride that feels like steven
spielberg's audition for disney world
the escape reaches a climactic moment
when indian pals are surrounded by the
baddies on a rope bridge extending over
a canyon a river teeming with crocodiles
lies several hundred feet below
out of safer options he offers up a
knowing glance to his sidekick short
round as he raises his sword to cut the
bridge he knows everyone including him
and his allies will be sent tumbling to
the cliffside along with the collapsing
bridge it seems extreme but staring
death in the face and smirking is just a
part of daily life for indiana jones oh
my god
oh my god
in the last crusade when indy finally
tracks down his abducted father's
location he's betrayed by his would-be
lover elsa the subtlety with which ford
and connery act out the realization they
both slept with the same woman as a
re-watchable moment all and of itself
here father and son end up being tied up
together as the nazis rummage through
all their research but the real fun
begins when connery fumbles a zippo
lighter and sends their lush prison up
in flames indiana's father are tied back
to back against some chairs and are
powerless to escape as the entire room
ignites into flames the two men hop
their way over to the fireplace to
escape the fire while frantically trying
to free himself from his restraint he
discovers that the fireplace has a
trapdoor leading to a nazi command room
not exactly the help they were hoping
for because the soldiers immediately
opened fire on them what follows is a
humorous sequence of events involving
deception and locking a bunch of nazis
in a makeshift furnace
it's not easy to pick just one moment
from this entire motorcycle chase in the
last crusade everything works together
beautifully to create an exciting
action-packed sequence that's also
modestly hilarious seeing the man who
defined james bond and a dorky hats and
glasses protecting his briefcase and
umbrella while refusing to acknowledge
his son's awesomeness speaks to the
essence of the last crusade indiana
jones and his father escape on a
motorcycle with a sidecar but their
would-be captors are in hot pursuit
after rolling through a barricade indy
grabs a flagpole and uses it as a lance
to knock an incoming nazi off his bike
the loose bike zips off and crashes into
several other pursuers the final
motorcycle batty is finished off when
indy uses the remaining fragment from
his makeshift lance and plunges it into
his enemies wheel spokes the only
acknowledgement he gets from his father
at this miraculous escape is an
expressionless face as he whines his
pocket watch typical
those pesky nazis always seem to find a
way to stay on indy's trail and bogart
any of his discoveries this time they
kidnap his father in an attempt to force
him to reveal the location of the holy
grail good thing henry jones jr can take
a punch and still think straight without
that presence of mind pops would be
squashed underneath the unforgiving
tread of a tank indy's father is being
kept inside a tank guarded by truckloads
of soldiers but andy blasts his way
through them all in order to help his
dad get out of the musty military
vehicle in a series of unfortunate
events papa jones falls onto the treads
and is about to be whisked off to his
death before indy pulls out his trusty
whip and latches it onto his father's
leg andy then has to hold on to the
weight of a full-grown man while a nazi
jerk pummels his kidneys it's an action
scene that proves indiana jones as the
alpha archaeologist
all roads lead indiana jones his
companions and their nazi captors to a
canyon housing a centuries-old temple
inside this temple is a series of booby
traps that can only be navigated with
decades of research and some quick
thinking behind all these contraptions
lies the holy grail the cup of christ is
known to be a source of immortality but
there are some caveats after water from
the cup heals henry jones senior's
gunshot wound the flip-flopping elsa
picks it up and begins excitedly
proclaiming that glory is theirs her
hubris causes her to forget the ancient
crusaders warning to never take the cup
past the temple seal the earth rumbles
and the ground breaks open to ultimately
send elsa falling to her doom india also
ends up falling into the same crevice
but his father grabs his hand at the
last moment the holy grail is barely out
of reach on an opposite ledge and indie
desperately reaches out outpour despite
his father's hands slipping connery
injects serenity into the chaos and
speaks softly indiana
let it go
it's a statement that carries an extreme
amount of weight it means father jones's
life's pursuit is meaningless next to
the life of his son
indiana jones in the kingdom of the
crystal skull had almost 20 years
between its release in 1989's the last
crusade and it was an absolute necessity
that we hit the ground running steven
spielberg made sure we got just that the
film opens in a government facility we
all recognize from the ending of the
first film a warehouse containing all
sorts of secrets the ark of the covenant
being one of them andy must not be very
good at choosing his friends because
he's betrayed once again by his
companion and forced to help the bad
guys find the treasure they seek andy
winds up escaping of course via a rocket
cart determined to shatter the land
speed record after that he ends up in a
small town which he slowly realizes is a
dummy town that's about to be on the
receiving end of a nuclear bomb test and
he hops inside a lead-lined refrigerator
and the blast launches him far away
where he stumbles out unscathed how
because he's indiana jones and we've
still got the rest of the movie to go
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite classic film franchises
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you